- [Voiceover] This great, big story
was made possible by Wells Fargo.
Established 1852, re-established 2018.
- [Voiceover] Every night during
the holy month Of Ramadan,
Muslims around the world attend an iftar-
a meal to break the day's religious fast.
But in Iran's holy city of Mashhad,
there is an iftar like no other.
- [Voiceover] (speaking
in foreign language)
- During the 30 days of Ramadan,
the Imam Reza mosque hosts a
break fast of epic proportions.
Every night as the sun sets,
thousands of meals are
served to hungry observers.
- [Voiceover] (speaking
in foreign language)
- [Voiceover] Cooking for that many people
can be a daunting job,
so they enlist the help
of over 400 volunteers.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- [Voiceover] To pull this off,
the volunteer chefs start
their day at five a.m.
and spend most of their time chopping
and stirring the evening's meal.
But 13,000 meals means a lot of food.
The mosque goes through 2
tons of fresh vegetables,
4 tons of rice,
and 3 tons of meat every single night.
- [Voiceover] (speaking
in foreign language)
- [Voiceover] But despite the challenges,
volunteers and patrons alike
consider it a great honor
to attend this special iftar.
- [Voiceover] (speaking
in foreign language)
(soft dinging)